[Music]
thank you
hello to all our viewers we just have a
announcement to Mike seeing seeing that
a lot of people have been asking what
app what's happened to Whatsapp Prof
Martin we only missed one episode right
yeah and people feel that something must
be a mess some people are asking is
everything fine with the ministry some
people are asking is this the end of
WhatsApp Prof and all of these
excitements out there
let us assure you
we have no intention of ending what's a
Prof yeah we have no intention of
changing the course of the ministry
in fact we are on fire
but just to put things a little bit into
perspective as to why it has been put on
hold for just a little while
is we were incredibly busy we have a lot
of projects we'll be telling you about
them in the very near future
and we had a few campaigns we had a lot
of traveling to do thousands of
kilometers
and we were under quite a lot of
strengths which we can also mention we
didn't do in the past three years
because of all the restrictions that
there were yes and you know we're in the
winter season and
you don't get the rest that you need so
we had a lot of traveling we did camp
meetings we did Regional camp meetings
and we had WhatsApp Prof to do and as it
happens in the winter season both of us
were a little bit under the weather
after a while
Martin got a serious flu yeah and he had
difficulty in keeping up and energies
were a bit low still we still we we're
still recovering yes we're recovering
and I got a bacterial infection
and that should put an end to all of
those speculations yes I had a bacterial
infection and it it wasn't fun but
there's a very positive spin-off I lost
a couple of kilos
yeah so we can so basically what we're
saying is we're just taking a tiny
little break and we'll keep going with
the programming and we have you know
wonderful people like Henry stoba who
jumps in and supplies information that
was pre-recorded
and just give us a week or two and we'll
be back on our feet back on fire
so I hope that puts everybody's mind to
rest there's no intention of
ever
for the foreseeable future stopping
WhatsApp Prof after all how can we we're
living in the last days and people need
to be prepared and get ready for what is
coming now's not a time to quit Now's
the Time to put the shoulder to the
wheel and we can also say watch this
space we'll be informing you of
interesting projects that we are busy
with yes because as we've said before
Martin
we believe the alpha message must be
integrated we we believe that the
workers are few
and there are many willing Souls but
they don't know how to do it so they
need a little bit of help we have
started initiatives to get that ball
rolling and we will keep you informed as
to all the projects that we are doing
and one more thing
we have big plans for the latter half of
this year
we have big campaigns coming up and we
have to prepare for those as well
so a little bit of breathing a little
bit of
time out from some of the other things
will really help us we've got a big
campaign coming in Europe
and that'll be at the end of October and
we are already praying that God will
bless that greatly
there's only very short windows of
opportunity
and then early next year we are going to
be involved in a very very big
Evangelistic Outreach
that will feature many many speakers and
it'll be very exciting because For the
First Time
people with the same drive for the Three
Angels messages will be on the same
platform we've been waiting for this for
a very very long time and it's time that
God's people
got together and showed some Unity when
it comes to spreading the Three Angels
messages yes what have you got to say
Martin well just for interest sake that
will be in South America yes would you
please end up with a word of prayer for
us for this
Endeavors that we are looking forward to
Dear listeners stay involved we are on
the road we are going to do what needs
to be done for the times that we are
living in let's pray
Heavenly Father
thank you Lord that you open so many
doors and provide so many opportunities
and thank you Lord for sending help when
help is needed
thank you for the many many
encouragements that we receive thank you
for the understanding of all the
listeners and may you bless and may you
bless Clash of mines and may you bless
the people
and may you bless the message that it
can go out to the world in a very very
direct manner so that all can understand
the issues for the times we are living
in we pray this in Jesus name amen amen
thank you